wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
ja bitte
du weißt nicht einmal was du willst was
willst du denn hier in deutschland
machen und was ist mit einem jurastudium
ich weiß was ich nicht will ich will
nicht weiterstudieren
das reicht nicht du bist auch einfach
aus spanien ricke kann und ich kann dir
sagen dass ein neuer anfang sehr schwer
ist und ohne deutschkenntnisse dass es
noch schwerer
ich hoffe dass ich über die sprache
jeden tag jahre und jetzt lerne ich noch
schneller
du hast keine arbeit ich suche mir
einfach so viel erfolg du denkst ich
schaffe das nicht
wie alle
okay aber du kümmerst dich um alles
wohnung job usw
ich mache das nicht für dich okay ich
helfe dir ein bisschen und du kannst es
erst einmal bei mir wohl danke und ich
will dass du weißt ja du du spricht kein
spanisch mehr ab jetzt sprichst du nur
noch deutsch dann lernst du die sprache
am besten du rufst sofort deine eltern
an
sie müssen wissen dass du bei mir bist
sowieso weil sie sich sorgen machen und
ich werde meine schwester nicht belügen
meine eltern verstehen kann deutsch sehr
witzig das wird nicht besser wenn du
länger warten